oh Mario Paul is the most painful topic
to discuss
we keep fingers crossed that we can
evacuate more civilians from mariupo as
a city and also from the as of style in
mariopal which is the last stronghold of
Ukraine in this in this city this
evocation is taking place under the
auspices of the United Nations
so the reputation of the United Nations
is also at stake in this process and we
are 100 open to working with them
because we need to save as many human
lives as possible but I cannot give you
a single guarantee of how many more
civilians we will uh we will be able to
evacuate you say the reputation of the
United Nations State their reputation is
at stake because if they fail
will be in the failure of the United
Nations but their success is down to
President Putin it's down to the Russian
forces if they will allow them to create
these human corridors that's that's
exactly the point we tried to negotiate
these corridors with Russia they always
cheated they always
tricked us and on this because you know
the difference between Russia and us is
that for Russia human life has no cost
but as I said the United Nations
invested their reputation in this
operation which we appreciate
and now everything depends on the
Russians yes but it will also be an
indicator of the impact that the United
Nations can make right so the United
Nations reputation depends now on
whether they can persuade or guterres
can persuade Putin to allow these
civilians out absolutely
um do you accept that mariapol is a city
is
probably lost now oh well this is a war
and uh
sometimes one party
captures territory and then we the other
party recaptures it I have no doubts
that in the end of the war in the end of
this war the Ukrainian flag will be
waving in Mario World
the mayor of Marriott poll whom I spoke
to the other day said that he thought
that the siege of mariopol
um
should be lifted by NATO forces he said
this was the reason for NATO forces to
come into this country a humanitarian
emergency
that is going on in mariopol do you
agree with him if NATO provides us with
all the necessary weapons to unblock
to lift the siege of mariopol we will do
it ourselves we don't need NATO soldiers
nicely weapons are you getting these
weapons and what sort of weapons are you
talking about
um the problem is that since the
beginning of this latest phase of the
war since 24th of February I do not see
NATO acting
as an alliance
in providing Ukraine with weapons
we see some allies providing us with
weapons but we do not see the entire
Alliance working on it so so NATO
as an alliance is not working
effectively in your view yes as an
alliance yes absolutely basically they
admitted that in countering Russian
aggression
um they cannot operate as an alliance
some allies are more active than others
the role of such NATO members as the
United Kingdom the United States Poland
turkey is crucial but I do not see NATO
operating as a as an alliance as a union
the British foreign secretary
Liz truss has said that she thinks that
heavier weapons should be supplied if
tanks should be supplied fighter jets
should be supplied
um do you agree with her and would you
want those weapons from the UK and other
Western countries the most pressing need
is
mlrs multiple launch rocket systems we
do need tanks
Western tanks not all Soviet tanks
anymore we need Western things but this
is but what we need the most the most
pressing issue is the one that I
mentioned mlrs but if there's even one
thing that is even more important
you know we can not rely on the supplies
of Soviet era weapons to Ukraine anymore
this is gone this is end of story
what we need is a comprehensive program
of transition from Soviet era weapons to
Nato standard weapons could the weapons
that you're talking about be the
difference between winning or losing
this war yes absolutely
not the entire War but some territories
we will we will lose some
Ukrainian territories and
the war will continue longer than it
than it should if we do not receive all
these weapons on time
can you see any
eventuality
uh which would mean that NATO troops
would be in Ukraine
not at this point the reason why
so many people in NATO countries
including politicians admire Ukraine
it's very simple
it's because Ukraine is not afraid of
Russia and they are
everyone wanted to kick Russia's ass
everyone
but no one dared
we were left with no choice your own
peace negotiations is there anything
going on
in the background that leads you to
think that there could be a negotiated
settlement soon
I do not expect a negotiated settlement
soon because Russia clearly preferred
War to negotiations they if you want to
talk you do not launch an offensive in
donbass by bringing thousands of people
and tanks and artillery pieces if you
want war if you want talks if you prefer
talks to war you do not beseech as of
style and shell them 24 hours per day if
you prefer talks to work you do not hit
uh Ukrainian citizen infrastructure
across the entire country with cruise
missiles I do not see any single
indicator that Russia is seriously uh
serious about negotiations could there
be any settlement at the end of this
that involves Ukraine giving up more
territory no you have to understand
we literally have no other option but to
win this war because the existence of
Ukrainian identity the existence of
Ukrainian nation is at stake
and we are not going to surrender under
any circumstances we are not going to
give away any single inch of our land to
them is Ukraine winning this war at the
moment yes
how does this end
the War I told you we will win
as simple as that because we have no
other choice